a championship in his first year he has
been around the block dough before we
got that job Jalen sent a cockatoo
first touch to the offensive entice
Gasol's got him on an OB try to stay
with brown Browns gets away fine
pretty brown comes away with it
jaelyn going hard to the basket the
floater for two empty dribble Tatum
comes up with the steal
he's got numbers on the break Brown to
the basket
there's a clock issue
take of his floater goes down about it
backs it off
[Applause]
Tatum it's a tree shooting percentage is
pretty low rebounds washdown +5 tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
Steele
kicks it 10 on the shot clock
Brown in the paint leaves in bility and
he didn't really know what to do with it
gets in the paint
[Music]
[Applause]
to the basket
Williams Lee exactly
Kentucky to steal
[Applause]
the bench is that break earlier Fouts
pass big flush jaylen Brown put some
broom paint takes it back to Williams
gives it up to brown dribble sewer
double-team and it's the little
following that's got numbers on the
break here hey whip the three fairies
[Applause]
[Music]
crowd mismatched turns gets to
had the mismatch and they took advantage
of it Walker cues it up gets it back
loop's inside to Williams corner
Dave Despard he wants to tree
the offensive glass
it's two out of it Williams skips it's a
smart three
if the role Williams got offensive
rebound Batum back to brown Jalen back
to smarts marks got taker
get by Williams found a six on the shot
clock
Lowry now off the bounce takes it to the
basket that's rejected the saw right
spot no we got Heyward beauty
[Applause]
there was a heck of a pass
what
flowery Gasol rejected Tatum turns the
corner back to Haywood open three Lowry
kicks out to brown
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content